guten abend und willkommen zu heute live
wir beschäftigen uns mit dem thema
rechtsextremismus in der polizei und
darüber spreche ich gleich mit sebastian
fiedler er ist vorsitzende des bundes
deutscher kriminalbeamter und auch ihr
könnt natürlich wieder mit diskutieren
mitmachen fragen stellen
zdf heute - live at zdf de lautet wie
immer die e mail adresse anlass für
unser gespräch ist der lagebericht zu
rechtsextremismus bei polizei und
geheimdiensten den heute mittag der
innenminister horst seehofer in berlin
vorgestellt hat und wir hören uns die
wichtigsten aussagen aus dieser
pressekonferenz jetzt schon einmal an
wir haben es mit einer geringen fallzahl
zu tun
das bedeutet auch dass wir kein
strukturelles problem mit
rechtsextremismus in den
sicherheitsbehörden von bund und ländern
haben muss man auch bei den geringen
zahlen deutlich sagen dass jeder
erwiesene fall eine schande ist es gilt
der grundsatz dass hier keinerlei
toleranz angezeigt ist
soweit also die kernaussagen aus der
pressekonferenz mit dem innenminister
sebastian fiedler ist uns zugeschaltet
einen schönen guten abend habe sie gar
schon vorgestellt sie sind vorsitzender
des bundes deutscher kriminalbeamter
bleiben wir doch gerade mal bei der
zentralen einschätzung von horst
seehofer ist gibt kein strukturelles
problem
teilen sie diese auffassung wieso habe
ich nur geahnt dass das ihre erste frage
sein würde
sie sind wahrscheinlich medien erfahren
ich werde mich da ja das mag sein ich
habe es ehrlich gesagt bei der
bundespressekonferenz schon geahnt dass
das heute die kernfrage sein würde
ich kann sie ihnen und will sie ihnen
deswegen nicht beantworten weil sie aus
meiner sicht total irrelevant ist weil
sie sich die frage aufdrängt was ist
denn jetzt genau ein strukturelles
problem sprechen wir jetzt über die
strukturen der chat gruppen sprechen wir
darüber ob jetzt die idee besteht dass
alle sicherheitsbehörden jetzt irgendwie
rechtsextreme sind das würde ich für
totalen humbug halten also lassen sie
bei den fokus darauf richten was denn
wohl jetzt die aussagen heute sind und
was wir daraus ableiten können dann ist
ja eigentlich die frage darauf zielt wir
sehen jetzt einen kleinen ausschnitt
oder wir sehen jetzt einen aktuellen
ausschnitten status quo das sind jetzt
noch weitere zahlen hinzu gekommen weil
wir müssen uns angucken was jetzt der
betrachtungszeitraum gewesen ist die
nordrhein-westfälischen fälle
beispielsweise kämen noch hinzu
die bundeswehr mit einer vierstelligen
anzahl käme noch hinzu das ist das was
wir erstmal sehen und von dort aus gibt
es jetzt viele fragezeichen denen sich
jetzt zunächst einmal das bundesamt für
verfassungsschutz insbesondere widmet
und eine analyse vornimmt und jetzt
fragen nachgeht ob und inwieweit
netzwerkstrukturen kennen verhältnisse
usw aufzudecken sind also das sehe ich
jetzt erstmal positiv weil wir jetzt
hier viel viel mehr erkenntnisse haben
als wir noch vor einem jahr gehabt
hätten herr fiedler jetzt haben sie
schon einen weiten bogen gespannt das
wollen wir in der tat auch gleich noch
mal mit ihnen gemeinsam aufdröseln
welche fragen sich jetzt daraus ergeben
wir wollen aber zunächst noch mal die
user auch mitnehmen nochmal auf die
wichtigsten ereignisse des tages schauen
und gucken nach berlin zu meinem
kollegen lassen sagt er hat das
zusammengestellt
immer wieder machen meldungen über
rassistische äußerungen bei der polizei
schlagzeilen
diesen internen chat bei whatsapp hat
ein polizeischüler in sachsen
offengelegt der mittlerweile frustriert
gekündigt hat also ich habe ganz
unterschiedlichen rassismus erlebt
aussagen von schieszler ja wir müssen
wieder gut schießen weil so viele
geflüchtete nach deutschland kommen oder
eben ganz blöde witze über muslime in
whatsapp chats für den innenminister
sind die fallzahlen im heute vorgelegten
lagebericht kein grund die
sicherheitsbehörden unter
generalverdacht zu stellen
die gesamtbewertung des berichts ist
deutlich wir haben es mit einer geringen
fallzahl zu tun und es bedeutet auch
dass wir kein strukturelles problem mit
rechtsextremismus in den
sicherheitsbehörden von bund und ländern
haben
die opposition will diesen befunden
nicht teilen unter anderem auch weil
seehofers zahlenwerk allein auf
freiwilligen meldungen beruhe dieser
lagebericht reicht bei weitem nicht aus
was wir dringend benötigen ist eine
tiefergehende wissenschaftliche analyse
über ausmaß und ursachen von
rechtsextremismus und rassismus in
unseren sicherheitsbehörden
denn der lagebericht dokumentiert ja nur
die fälle die sowieso schon öffentlich
bekannt sind
dieses lagebild kommt viel zu spät es
fehlt ihm an der nötigen aussagekraft
und das bundesinnenministerium zieht
nicht die richtigen schlüsse ein ist
jedoch will der innenminister unbedingt
klarstellen
jeder einzelfall ist eine schande für
die sicherheitsbehörden die
grundsätzliche frage aber ob es
strukturellen rechtsextremismus und
rassismus bei der polizei gibt hat
weiterhin politisch umstritten
also kein strukturelles problem sagte
innenminister wohl aber eine schande und
jeder einzelfall müsse eben aufgeklärt
werden und zwar konsequent haben sie
herr fiedler den eindruck dass das auch
genau so geschieht was meinen sie dass
er das heraus dass die aufklärung
konsequent stadt bin ich ja das können
wir ja nicht nur anhand von der
fragestellung beantworten was horst
seehofer tut weil wir ja noch 16 länder
mit in die waagschale werfen müssen und
ich erlebe jedenfalls beispielsweise in
nordrhein westfalen dass auch dort ein
ganzes bündel von maßnahmen jetzt
ergriffen wird
ich habe zur kenntnis genommen was horst
seehofer und die drei präsidenten der
sicherheitsbehörden dort heute gesagt
haben also es passiert tatsächlich sehr
sehr viel im moment vor allen dingen
wenn wir das vergleichen mit dem was in
den letzten jahren passiert ist nämlich
vergleichsweise wenig muss man sagen
also insoweit ist das schon ein großer
fortschritt aber es gibt meine ich noch
viel viel zu diskutieren was auch weit
über die sicherheitsbehörden
hinausreicht ein wichtiger oder ein
hauptkritikpunkt war dass die meldungen
freiwillig waren und damit eventuell das
problem besteht dass da natürlich ein
dunkelfeld herrscht in diese richtung
fragt auch unsere user in frankleben auf
facebook sie sagt das ist keine gute
datengrundlage das hat überhaupt keine
aussagekraft da oft gar nicht erst
ermittelt wird oder oft unzureichend die
frage nach dem dunkelfeld wie würden sie
die beantworten muss tatsächlich
gestehen ich hab das eben bei trag mich
auch schon gefragt was da wohl mit
gemeint sein könnte dass sie jetzt sagen
das seien freiwillige meldung das kann
ich nicht so ganz nachvollziehen
also es handelt sich hier um fälle bei
denen das ist ja dezidiert heute
vorgetragen worden in der
pressekonferenz bei denen entweder
strafverfahren schon betrieben sind
strafverfahren abgeschlossen sind leute
schon entlassen worden sind
disziplinarverfahren laufen vielleicht
ist genau gesagt worden in der quantität
wie viele verfahren noch aktiv
laufen also kann man ja nicht nur
wirklich von freiwilligen meldungen
reden vielleicht ist damit gemeint
gewesen dass die länder freiwillig an
das bundesamt für verfassungsschutz
gemeldet haben das ist allerdings auch
kein zu reichen das bild weil auch
erhalten heute dargestellt hat dass er
ja mit den länder zusammen gesessen hat
und man dort weiter daran arbeitet wie
man diese meldung noch schneller machen
kann die man sie harmonisiert also dass
nun wirklich echt nicht so das größte
problemfeld wenn wir uns fragen wie wir
das dunkelfeld mehr erhellen können dann
können wir das nur so erhellen das wir
mechanismen in den sicherheitsbehörden
einziehen die die masse der mitarbeiter
stärken nämlich in die möglichkeit
eröffnen wenn sie in solche gruppen
gefüge hineingeraten und sich nicht
trauen ohne berufliche nachteile so
etwas zu melden
dann brauchen wir solche melde kanäle in
der wirtschaft würde man das
hinweisgebersysteme nennen das ist etwas
was auch die polizeibehörden schon seit
langer zeit betreiben beispielsweise um
korruptions hinweise entgegen zu nehmen
das ist so etwas über das wir
diskutieren müssen das dürfte der
wirksamste mechanismus sein um die
dunkel felder zu erhellen inwieweit
haben sie denn das gefühl dass der chor
geist der mit sicherheit auch hin und
wieder in manchen polizeieinheiten
vorherrschen mag das deren problem ist
dabei sie sagen jetzt ist müssten
eventuell anlaufstellen geschaffen
werden wenn ich sie richtig verstanden
habe die externen gelagert sind
ja das wäre der nächste schritt und
diesmal habe ich gesprochen über diese
hinweisgebersysteme das heißt sie sind
kanäle da sind auch technische kanäle
die ich damit meine
die ermöglichen auch wissenschaftlern
hinterher auswertungen zu treffen und
die frage ist was hängt am ende des
kanals und da wäre
in meiner vorstellung tatsächlich im
idealfall eine externe stelle mit
expertinnen und experten die
juristischen psychologischen
sachverstand haben denn kunst ist immer
sehr negativ behaftet ist aber zunächst
einmal gar nichts negatives sondern eher
was positives wir müssen daran denken
dass wir die organisationseinheiten
haben wo der eine dem anderen sein leben
im einsatz anvertraut deswegen ist das
durchaus gut und richtig dass es dort in
engen zusammenhalt gibt und zu gruppen
gefüge
das ist kein spezifikum der
polizeibehörden das gibt es überall da
gibt es jahrzehntelange forschung wie
konformität in gruppen funktioniert das
gruppen bindungen und gruppen zwenger
sehr sehr enge und starke psychologische
mechanismen sind das wissen wir lange
und deswegen ist die frage wie können
wir wenn der missstände auftreten in
solchen gruppen diese missstände zu tage
befördern und da liefert das die
entsprechende antwort niederschwellige
möglichkeiten müssen wir eröffnen um
solche dinge zutage zu befördern
also insofern können sie auch den
innenminister beipflichten der ja gesagt
hat es würde sich dabei also beim
hinsehen sozusagen auch innerhalb des
kollegen kreises nicht um
denunziantentum handeln sondern das sei
die pflicht eines jeden beamten denn man
habe ja auch eben einen eid auf die
verfassung geschworen
das ist genau 100 prozentig zu
unterschreiben
die frage ist nur welche konsequenzen
daraus zu ziehen sind und da gibt es
eben unterschiedliche antworten der zeit
der präsident der bundespolizei mit
hohmann hat heute dargestellt wie die
bundespolizei das gelöst hat sie hat
eine interne stelle geschaffen die
unmittelbar ihm untersteht
andere sagen ich würde mich den zu
rechnen dass es doch noch etwas
sinnvoller wäre außerhalb der
polizeilichen organisation profis daran
zu setzen um die meldeschwelle noch
entsprechend geringer zu halten ohne
dass man auch nur im ansatz diese
vokabel denunziantentum oder ähnliches
in der mund wird das ist eine sehr
unprofessionell vokabel denn wir kennen
ja meldesysteme auch gerade als
kriminalpolizei schon in anderen
bereichen wie ich gerade schon sagte
beispielsweise korruptions hotlines und
vielleicht auch noch mal eine andere
stimme hier zu wort kommen zu lassen bei
uns leon heine auf facebook schreibt
lasst doch die polizei in ruhe die
mehrheit der deutschen schätzt die
beamten und weiß dass sie nicht einfach
irgendwie zusammen schlagen oder gar
nazis sind also wie gesagt wir bilden
auch immer ab was unsere user umtreibt
ich würde noch gerne auf den aspekt zu
sprechen kommen dass die zahlen in den
bundesländern auch ziemlich
unterschiedlich ausfallen hessen hat mit
59 etwa die meisten verdachtsfälle
sachsen zum beispiel 28
schleswig-holstein 3 das saarland hat
gar keinen verdachtsfall gemeldet liegt
das jetzt daran dass in hessen genauer
hin
geschaut wird oder hat das andere gründe
ja in hessen dürfte uns beiden ja
bekannt sein also rund um diesen
sogenannten selbsternannten nsu 2.0 hat
das dort natürlich riesenwirbel gewesen
viele maßnahmen die der innenminister
jetzt eingezogen hat nach über zwei
jahren wo dieses problem dort virulent
ist sie wissen in nordrhein westfalen
sind die zahlen mehr oder weniger
zufällig entstanden weil in einem völlig
anderen sachverhalt ermittlungen
betrieben worden sind und dann auf
diesem handy was dort beschlagnahmt
worden ist diese jet gruppe auf gekippt
ist
also lautet doch die aufgabe tatsächlich
wie können wir uns nicht sehr von
zufällen abhängig machen die dann in den
ländern zu solchen fällen führen sondern
wie können wir strukturen schaffen die
genau das deutlich machen was der user
den sie gerade zitiert haben quasi als
wunsch formuliert hat und was ich auch
so wahr nehme ich bin nach wie vor der
überzeugung dass tatsächlich der
überwiegende teil der bevölkerung ein
sehr hohes vertrauen in die
sicherheitsbehörden nicht aber was uns
natürlich stört ist dass wir ständig
über diese fälle diskutieren müssen wie
diese chat fälle in nordrhein westfalen
wie den selbsternannten nsu 2.0 wie ein
sogenanntes hannibal netzwerk in
mecklenburg vorpommern das sind alles
fälle die uns nachhaltig stören uns
stören die am allermeisten weil es weil
das die wahren nestbeschmutzer sind da
sind diejenigen die nichts mit dem ernst
genommen haben und nur wenn wir diese
diskussion eliminieren dann können wir
auch ruhe in den laden bringen und das
wäre eigentlich unser vornehmste wunsch
weil auch ich die überzeugung habe dass
der weit überwiegende teil
die masse der beschäftigten tatsächlich
hier keine probleme hat ja das wollen
wir auch nicht in abrede stellen um das
vielleicht auch noch mal deutlich zu
machen jetzt haben sie gerade schon
einige beispiele genannt vielleicht weiß
nicht jeder user oder jeder zuschauer
was damit genau gemeint ist meine
kollegin nina niebergall hat noch einmal
die ereignisse der letzten wochen und
monate
zusammengefasst mit den dingen über die
herr fiedler verständlicherweise nicht
allzu gerne spricht aber die wir
trotzdem noch mal zeigen wollen
sie sollen geflüchtete mit ratten
verglichen muslime massiv herabgewürdigt
haben es ist der jüngste fall in einer
ganzen reihe von fällen 25 berliner
polizisten hätten sich jahrelang im chat
gruppen ausgetauscht rassistisch
rechtsextrem berichtete das ard-magazin
monitor ermittlungen laufen
auch in nordrhein westfalen wird gegen
29 beamte ermittelt im chat gruppen
schickten sie sich regelmäßig bilder
die behörden sprechen von übelster
rassistischer neonazistischer hetze
allesamt wurden suspendiert
und dann sind da noch die droh mails
unterzeichnet mit enescu 2.0 eine
anlehnung an die rechtsextreme
terrorzelle nationalsozialistischer
untergrund die mails gingen zahlreiche
bekannte personen meistens frauen
die daten dafür kommen von
polizeicomputer zunächst von hessischen
der inzwischen führen spuren auch nach
hamburg berlin und bayern
wenn wir uns diese fälle jetzt anschauen
auch in dieser häufung und in dieser
verteilung kann man denn daraus
schließen dass es sich um netzwerke
handelt ja die fälle haben jetzt erstmal
auf den ersten blick war zumindest nach
meiner information miteinander direkt
nichts zu tun aber dass es sich bei dem
laut kreutz was ich gerade schon sagt um
ein netzwerk handelt durch auf den tisch
legen der generalbundesanwalt ermittelt
da noch immer und bei den anderen fällen
wissen wir schlicht und ergreifend zu
wenig deswegen habe ich ja gerade
positiv hervorgehoben dass der präsident
des bundesamtes für verfassungsschutz
erhalten waren heute deutlich gemacht
hat dass die fälle die er jetzt
vorgestellt hat heute in der statistik
nicht einfach nur eine statistik bleiben
sondern dass die analyse sich jetzt
genau darauf konzentriert um mit den
möglichkeiten die die
sicherheitsbehörden haben zu ermitteln
ob es dort netzwerke gibt ob dort kennen
verhältnis untereinander bestehen um
genau dem tatsächlich auf den grund zu
gehen das ist gut aber das müssen so
lange bis wir mehr erkenntnisse haben ja
also genau das ist jetzt gegenstand der
derzeitigen ermittlungen ein weiterer
großer kritikpunkt ist ja die weigerung
von minister seehofer eine unabhängige
studie zu rassismus in der polizei
zuzulassen weil er sagt das sei eben ein
gesamtgesellschaftliches problem und es
sei nicht legitim die polizei heraus
zugreifen und sie quasi damit so an den
pranger zu stellen
sie haben eine andere auffassung ja wir
sind mit unserer auffassung wäre schon
etwas länger unterwegs wir haben schon
in unserer bundesvorstand sitzung im
september 2009 10 dazu eine forderung
erhoben
und da war gerade eben der
selbsternannte nsu 2.0 und dieses
hannibal netzwerk und so das waren
gerade so die ereignisse die uns
überhaupt dazu gebracht haben uns näher
dazu mit zu beschäftigen und unsere
forderung war gerade eben eine
wissenschaftliche untersuchung und jetzt
gab es noch einen wichtigen punkt den
wir uns vorgestellt haben dass eine
untersuchung tatsächlich auch bundesweit
also bundesländer plus bund miteinander
harmonisiert wird so dass wir da breite
erkenntnisse haben zu den studien die
horst seehofer angeregt hat also
insbesondere der gesellschaftlichen
studie gibt es schon längst also die
erkenntnisse liegen seit vielen jahren
auf dem tisch denken sie an die mitte
studie die von der
friedrich-ebert-stiftung herausgegeben
wird
all diese erkenntnisse haben wir schon
eine weitere studie hat er jetzt
angekündigt oder zwei weitere hatte
angekündigt zum einen die betrachtung
der rahmenbedingungen der polizeilichen
arbeit das ist gut und richtig dass
würde ich durchaus unterschreiben plus
eine studie die sich mit der gewalt
gegen die sicherheitsbehörden
beschäftigt der teil der jetzt
allerdings noch fehlen würde um das um
das puzzle tatsächlich vollständig zu
machen ist
wir müssen der frage nachgehen wie ist
es mit den einstellungen derjenigen die
in den sicherheitsbehörden arbeiten denn
bestellt und das müssen wir aus einem
ganz einfachen grund tun weil wir
anschließend ja risikomanagement
betreiben wollen wir müssen analysieren
in welchen organisationseinheiten gibt
es große risiken tatsächlich vorurteile
herauszubilden und in welchen gibt es
geringere risiken weil nur so können wir
zielgerichteter unsere kolleginnen und
kollegen auch unterstützen
das heißt also sie wären für eine studie
die genau eben das zum gegenstand hat ja
das ist unsere forderungen seit über
einem jahr
wir haben jens jordan auf youtube der
sagt ich frage mich kann ich polizistin
irgendwo melden damit eventuelle
rechtsextreme hintergründe untersucht
werden also ich als bürger sozusagen an
zahllosen stellen allerdings leben wir
jetzt im föderalismus deswegen fällt mir
die antwort alleine aus diesem grunde
etwas schwer weil die bundesländer dort
unterschiedliche strukturen geschaffen
haben
wenn sie nach rheinland pfalz gucken da
gibt es so einen bürgerbeauftragten das
haben einige länder eingerichtet oder
tun dass gerade wenn es sich um
strafrechtlich relevante sachverhalte
handelt dann können die
selbstverständlich bei der
staatsanwaltschaft bei der polizei
angezeigt und das ist ein im
innenministerium jeweils was ankommt
gibt es dort ein beschwerdemanagement
der petitionsausschuss des landtages
also wir haben unterschiedliche würde
fast sagen zahlreiche möglichkeiten sich
zu beschweren und was man häufig so
abtut dass man sagt ja die polizei
ermittelt da ja nicht gegeneinander oder
so das kann ich nicht bestätigen unser
berufsbild macht das gerade eben aus
dass wir es auch gewohnt sind natürlich
gegen mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern
im jeweiligen fall wenn es denn an
strafrechtlich im verdacht gibt auch zu
ermitteln
das naja will nur sagen also es gibt das
hängt von den bundesländern abhängige
strukturen so bestatter es gibt immer
mittel und wege ingo schmökel auf
facebook schreibt die polizei ist so
rechts und so links wie die mitglieder
jeder anderen behörde oder institution
sind alles menschen das vielleicht auch
noch mal ein naja zumindest halbwegs
versöhnlicher satz aber die probleme
bleiben natürlich und man muss gerade
bei der polizei als natürlich den naja
ausübenden beamten auf was die
hoheitliche gewalt angeht genauer
hinschauen das ist auch klar wovon der
innenminister er gesprochen hat und was
sie auch gerade noch einmal angesprochen
haben ist ja die studie oder die
untersuchung des arbeitsalltags der
polizisten
inwieweit hängt das also auch die
tägliche gewalt erfahrung die viele
ihrer kollegen ja machen mit dem problem
zusammen über das wir jetzt hier heute
abend sprechen inwieweit hat das mit
zwei mal der einstellungs bildung auch
einzelner beamten vielleicht zu tun
also ich würde sagen vieles wissen wir
nicht das ist ja der grund dafür warum
wir vielleicht wissenschaftler ran
lassen sollten aber ich würde durchaus
so weit gehen und würde sagen das wird
höhere risiken als andere bereiche also
das heißt wenn das arbeitsumfeld nicht
stimmt wenn es dienstgruppen gibt die in
stadtquartieren arbeiten bei denen dass
die kolleginnen und kollegen tatsächlich
sehr häufig mit straftätern zu tun haben
die keinen deutschen pass haben dann ist
das risiko aufrechte narrativer zuhören
und vorurteile herauszubilden
möglicherweise nicht mehr zu
differenzieren dass man mit seinem
polizeilichen alltag nicht die
gesamtheit der gesellschaft vor der nase
hat diese risiken sind durchaus gegeben
das kann man glaube ich kaum in abrede
stellen
die frage ist jetzt tatsächlich was tun
wir da was tun die dienstherren da und
da würde ich an dieser stelle sagen
eindeutig zu wenig da müssen sich die
dienstherren mehr auch um diese
kolleginnen und kollegen kümmern
die rahmenbedingungen der arbeit
verbessern dann wäre schon mal glaube
ich ein erster schritt getan aber das
muss teil einer solchen professionell
eine risikoanalyse sein
ansonsten kommen wir da nicht wirklich
weiter dieser appell dann noch mal zum
schluss sebastian fiedler war das
vorsitzender des bundes deutscher
kriminalbeamter vielen dank für das
gespräch dass sie sich die zeit für uns
genommen haben heute abend dankeschön
und liebe user natürlich noch mal vielen
dank fürs reinschauen und auch für das
eifrige mitmachen wir hoffen es hat euch
ein bisschen was gebracht an erkenntnis
gewinnen wir wünschen euch einen schönen
abend und sagen schau bis zum nächsten
mal
[Musik]